That's a tough question,
but I mean we don't have a lot of
natural resources as a country.
We have a very beautiful country
visually.
I mean everyone goes out about green
that's in the mountains and the rivers
and it's clean and it's not populated.
It is stunningly beautiful,
but we've no oil.
We've no cold with no money.
We just have our Ireland,
but we're theory I have is we come from
a suppressed culture.
We're,
we're,
we're one of the most invaded countries
ever.
I think the British started very early,
could be like $800.
I decided to come and show us at the
Danes and the norse and we've had a
tough time,
but pretty much a similar culture would
be to Jewish culture.
They had a pretty hard time,
uh,
there were being kicked around for a
long,
long time.
So when that happens,
when people try to take your culture
away from you and your assets of your
culture becomes stronger,
it's like even in Africa,
you know,
when you see African Americans,
they're stronger because of what they've
gone through.
It's even sublingual.
I think it becomes in the genes,
but our language was even taken from us.
Uh,
the Irish Gaelic language was outlawed
at the religion was outlawed,
hence the religion later being stronger,
stronger to a negative point of view.
Uh,
but our revenge was.
I mean,
if you listen to Irish language,
it's,
it's very complicated,
but it's very poetic to say hello and
Ireland is weakest.
Lydia,
which translated means sunshine of God
on you.
And that's a lot nicer than hello.
You know what I mean?
And goodbye as slung Ghanaian Jambo,
her laugh which made it's a wave and may
the road rise,
which you,
which is a very well known phrase and
that's a really nice way to say goodbye.
So there was ingrained poetry.
And then when you look back at our
history in the 20th century,
the last century,
probably the greatest writers of the
20th century were Irish.
You go from Beckett to Joyce to being,
to,
to Shaw,
to Oscar Wilde.
He just go,
Jesus,
what's going on here?
All these guys.
And,
and the most famous book in the world
could be ulysses after the Bible.
But that was almost like a revenge on
how dare you take our culture from us.
So it became our only weapon was our
poetry or music.
And if you listen to Irish music,
I think we've more than say the celts
came from the Middle East.
So really I'm an Arab.
She listened to the way they said,
listen,
listen to a similar,
like Sinead O'connor site,
you know,
you could be Muslim,
you know that anx,
that's another layer that whale.
So,
uh,
I think it's in our genes.
I think certain stuff is in our genes,
like nobody can dance like a black guy.
It's in the genes so we don't have oil,
but we have poetry
for the not very well.
I,
I'm not a huge fan of the Celtic tiger.
I was so glad that you could see people
being prosperous and you didn't see
people begging that the city started
looking good,
that people had jobs.
But it's almost like if you have such a
hard time for so long,
then you turn around and give a kid a
check for a million quid,
they're going to go nuts.
And we went a bit nuts.
We went up,
harass,
certainly everyone started sounding very
American,
which freaked me at the.
Oh my God syndrome kicked in really
quick and I,
I got a fright at the bubble is burst
time,
towels,
time tells everything we,
we blew it too quickly,
you know,
but it wasn't totally our fault because
the big boys that run those banks,
they messed up America.
They've missed,
it's up Europe,
they've messed up the world.
And really it's the start of the 21st
century.
We've got to rethink things.
Socialism and communism don't work but
needed a straightforward capitalism.
We've got to get a new way of thinking
and working.
We blew it.
So there was good and bad about about
the Celtic tiger.
But we're tiny,
right?
This 4 million in the country,
do you know what I mean?
We're tiny.
4 million in the country and he's in New
York.
Seven 10,
you know?
But uh,
but we're strong.
So hopefully we pulled through and you
never really know until you get
perspective copany years away.
But I really disliked the fact that our
culture is what make us.
And made us and will make us.
And when money came in,
we rejected it so quickly.
Not even rejected.
We didn't think.
We just got lazy and all the girls
started getting fast.
And that's not good.
Is it?